my son I told him I was going to
interview you today and he was showing
me clips this morning and I saw the rant
you did about your aunt how my mother is
in an asylum and
and Beyond me and it's beyond everybody
you are a disgrace I don't even know if
you can talk about that because I think
it led to a suit she didn't sue me oh
she but she did come close to it I would
be worried that you'd sue me but you
don't know how to practice law you're
not a real lawyer are you she was very
unhappy about that yeah but she started
started it and then you called her a
pedophile that is true
keep my name out of your mouth okay
pedophile drug addict
that was a big
yeah